bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors il y à ce regain
épidémique en europe mais finalement on
a l'impression qu'il ya deux blocs qui
se distinguent les pays de l'est et les
autres relativement épargné en tout cas
pour l'instant pourquoi selon vous
bonsoir
déjà il faut réfléchir au fait qui ne
l'a pas dans le bloc de l'est comme vous
l'appelez
il ya un moment elle avait la
vaccination a été fait avec les
actions russes spoutnik donc
déjà ça au niveau couverture vaccinale
on sait pas si le niveau des couvertures
qui donnait pas les spoutniks est
comparable à celle qui m'a parlé
par les vaccins qui n'ont été utilisés
d'ailleurs dans l'europe de l'ouest si
on retourne au paint arriérés des globes
et varsovie contre des blocs à
l'atlantique donc ne pas voir ça il peut
voir aussi les différences des gestes
barrières et aussi du fait qu'il ya du
première vague au vide ils ont frappé le
plus beau couple fort du côté atlantique
de l'europe doit créer les côtés de
l'ordre dé l'est et 11 blessés par des
amis les collègues par exemple il ya des
pics aussi aussi des décors vides donc
si possible aussi qu'il ya là les
échanges économiques commerciaux et
touristiques il souffre est beaucoup
plus des ces pays vers l'a16 plutôt que
des les pays et des goûts du bloc
atlantique
donc c'est sûr qu'il s'appelle jouer
dans différents
styles qui n'a aujourd'hui dans l'europe
de l'est par rapport aux pays
méditerranée atlantique en tout cas on
allemagne ans n'est pas tout nick v qui
a été utilisé 11 qu'il ya beaucoup de
cas de contamination en ce moment en
allemagne d'ailleurs la chancelière a
pris la parole ce matin et elle a appelé
justement les réfractaires à se faire
vacciner vous êtes à milan vous en
italie est donc quelle est la situation
sur place vous êtes médecin est-ce que
vous la sentez cette vague épidémique
qui déferle sur l'autre même si en
italie elle est moins importante que
dans d'autres pays
effectivement en italie les noms tel
portable il faut aussi et bien réfléchir
aux différentes étapes nous on était
moins en première ligne que la première
vague frappé et europe et la partie
était vraiment elle est
négative de cette épidémie et qu'il est
mis pour la première vraiment à
être confronté en 2020 donc
effectivement
l'aller j'espère hier et
la prise de conscience du rider ces
virus fait que les gens sont plus
attentifs par exemple on n'a jamais
relâché l'utilisation du masque à
l'intérieur donc ça déjà c'est qu'un
nombre très important il faut pas non
plus négliger
il est chez kébé
la diffusion du virus il y aussi voilà
aux attitudes ça ce que les écoles un
mythe ali et loulou beaucoup plus tard
que dans tous les autres pays d y aura
la reprise des scolaires si la finma
septembre donc il ya un décalage aussi
sur la reprise des bio is par rapport
aux que les activités qu'il prend des
façons différentes
après il faut aussi pas oublier qu'il a
on parlait des patients contaminés ont
fait beaucoup plus des tests déjà folle
histoire du grille pain sans même les
gens qui sont pas vaccinés s'ils vont
tester tous les trois jours donc
forcément plus on teste plus on a des
tests positifs et après je trouve que ça
s'est vraiment autant que métier c'est
vraiment les grandes oubliées
aujourd'hui c'est la médecine on vaccine
les gens dans des mains des hommes sans
vraiment faire des études du cas par cas
on teste les gens mais l'été c'est
jusque et moyennes des diagnostics mai
un diagnostic il faudrait qu'ils soient
posées par un médecin c'est pas parce
qu'elle vous avez une thèse positive que
vous êtes malade et ça je trouve c'est
vraiment la chose est friand au départ
début d'épidémie effectivement on était
des prévu il en fallait faire avec les
moyens du bord aujourd'hui avec tous les
reculs je trouve que la médecine et il
devrait plaindre que l'auteur il veut
reprendre sa position centrale
diagnostic dans les thérapies dans la
détection est ici dans la santé publique
alors qu'il a beaucoup plus des choix
qui à mon sens apparaître politique que
mehdi claque alors dernière question on
le sait qu'en autriche on réfléchit un
confinement de non vaccinés ce sera à
l'étude de demain par le parlement est
ce que c'est un choix judicieux selon
vous en tant que médecin en tant que
médecine pour moi c'est pas un choix
médical on retourne au discours d'écouté
là c'est le choix politique
d'abord c'est des clients qu'ils ont
pris par les hommes politiques et par
les médecins en tant que médecin on pc
on peut dire qu'ils ont va confiné et
hunter il faudrait confier les personnes
à risque donc c'est possible et que les
non vaccinés sur des personnes à risque
il m'est encore encore faut-il décidé
par exemple qu'est-ce qu'il faut
continuer quelqu'un qui a 30 ans qui est
en bonne santé et qu'ils aient pas
déclenché des risques je ne sais pas et
sachant aussi que les vaccins comme
tutelle ils sont pas les vaccins comme
on a connu auparavant parce qu'elle est
il n'empêche pas
d'être
décontracté a gelé les empêche d'être
malade mais n'empêche pas de contracter
le virus il n'empêche pas des
transmettre le virus alors on se revoit
pourquoi on confine skis on confine pour
protéger les plus fragiles est ce qu on
confine pour pousser des gens qui n'ont
pas été vaccinés a sélectionné les
décisions sont déjà trop tard qu'elle
était nous on ira est confiné les gens
fragiles et les gens à risque mais comme
tu ne parles pas
vacciner si vous voyez ces
critiques on peut dire que vous n'êtes
pas actionner pour vous comme film comme
ça vous êtes pousser à être vaccinés
effectivement les faits de crime
vacciner permet de voir des formes
graves de la maladie et du coude et
moins engorgés les hôpitaux c'est ça la
différence
comprendre merci en tout cas pour autre
éclairage umberto jeu vannini je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
chirurgien à milan et milan vous étiez
en direct avec nous depuis cette ville
merci à vous